WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
YOU OFFER HIRE BREAKING NEWS
THAT IS IMPORTANT AND THIS ONE
IS.
AND IT IS SHOCKING.
ACCORDING TO NEW REPORTS THAT
THE FBI MAY HAVE HAD A SPY IN OR
ACTING WITHIN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
A GOVERNMENT SPY IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF INFORMATION THAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION MAY HAVE
BEEN SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
WHY ARE WE LEARNING ABOUT IT
NOW?
APPARENTLY THE FBI AND DOJ HID
THAT INFORMATION FROM CONGRESS.
CONGRESS HAS THE AUTHORITY OVER
THE FBI.
IT IS NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND
AS MUCH AS THE FBI WOULD LIKE TO
BELIEVE THAT.
DPROSZ MISCONDUCT IS NOTHING NEW
IN THE FBI OF JIM COMEY.
IN THIS IS TRUE, THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WOULD HAVE DONE
THAT.
BUT B, YOU HAVE TO PRESS
CAREFULY ON THE DETAILS.
WHAT TO YOU KNOW IN
>> YOU PRAY THE STORY IS NOT
TRUE.
THAT IS NOT A PARTISAN VEG.
THE VERY IDEA OF OUR GOD GIVEN
RIGHTS SCLEEDED AND THEY PRODUCE
HARD EVIDENCE OF A CRIME AND YET
A HUMAN INTELLIGENCE ASSET MAY
HAVE BEEN INSERTED IN YOUR
POLITICAL RIVAL CAMPAIGN?
HOW THIS IS NOT FRONT PAGE NEWS
ACROSS THE GLOBE IS STUNNING.
REMEMBER THAT DEVIN NUNEZ HAD
ANOTHER BOMBSHELL THAT THERE WAS
NO OFFICIAL FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
THROUGH OFFICIAL CHANNELS
PASSING TO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT WAS A HUGE BOMBSHELL.
HE DIDN'T SAY IT DIDN'T PASS
THROUGH UNOFFICIAL CHALLENGE.
POTENTIALLY THAT INFORMATION WAS
LAUNDERING THROUGH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND POTENTIALLY U.S.
SENATE AND POTENTIALLY A HUMAN
ASSET IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: HAS THIS EVER
HAPPENED OR ALLEGED BEFORE IN
A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN?
>> NOT IN THE UNITED STATES.
I AM SURE IT HAPPENED IN PIE
NOVELS AND THIRD WORLD COUNTRY
S.
BUT TUCKER, IT IS SO
UNBELIEVABLE ON ITS FACE.
IT IS LIKE A THICK SPY NOVEL YET
IT HAPPENED.
IF YOU GAVE IT A TO A BOOK AGENT
THEY MIGHT LAUGH AND SAY IT IS
SO ABSURD AND COULD NEVER
HAPPEN.
I HAVE MY SUSPICIONS ABOUT WHO
THE ASSET IS AS DO MANY OTHERS
BY THE WAY.
IT WILL BE EXPLOSIVE WHEN THE
NAME COMES OUT.
THE LIST OF SUSPECTS ARE VERY
SHORT AND THEY ARE CONNECTED IN
OURIGENCE SCOMBRENS COMMUNITY
NOW.
AND THIS IS IT A KEY POINT,
TUCKER AND CONNECTED TO
POLITICAL OPERATIVES AND
CONNECTED TO FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE ASSETS AS WELL.
IT IS SERIOUS STUFF AND NOT
A JOKE.
AND LIKE YOU SAID BEFORE.
I WISH NONE OF THIS WAS TRUE AND
IT APPEARS SADLY IT IS.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A CRIME TO
BEGIN WITH.
IS THERE EVIDENCE THAT THE FBI
WAS RECEIVING INFORMATION FROM
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN THE
CAMPAIGN IN
>> YES, I BELIEVE THERE IS MORE
THAN ONE SOURCE FOR THE FBI.
WHETHER THERE WAS MORE ONE
SOURCE PAID MAY BE A DIFFERENT
STORY.
I BELIEVE ON BASED ON REPORTING
IT IS ALREADY OUT THERE.
AND I AM TELLING YOU THINGS THAT
ARE OUT THERE IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN.
THERE IS A NUMBER OF NAMES OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONNECTED TO THE
OBAMA TEAM.
ONE PERSON IS REPRESENTED BY THE
FORMER WHITE HOUSE LAWYER.
WAS PRESENT IN THE MEETING BOB
MUELLER IS INVESTIGATING.
AND IT WAS WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONNECTED WITH THE CLINTONS.
ONE OF THE GUYS AT THE MEETING
IS LITERALLY REPREPONDERATED BY
OBAMA'S FORMER WHITE HOUSE
LAWYER AND WORKED WITH ANDY
WISEMAN AND THEY WERE ON THE
ENRON PROSECUTION.